(upbeat music)
- I've always been interested
to see what I would look
like with long hair.
- This is about as long
as I've ever had my hair.
- I look forward to doing a lot of this
and a lot of that.
- If you wanna head bang
if you have long hair,
that's like the whole reason.
- If I like the long
hair, I'm definitely gonna
grow my hair out.
(upbeat music)
- What?
- Whoa!
Whoa.
- Pssst.
What?
- I'm like a very feminine Khal Drogo.
- I look like I'm on the
cover of like some stupid
romance novel.
Hey.
- Bet you so much money
people are gonna walk by me
and be like, Jesus!
- I look like a very disappointing geisha.
- I just feel like I put on
that voice the whole time.
Hey, where's the organic produce?
- Do I have to wear this
every time I go out?
- Let the week begin.
- Ricky just did my hair.
- You look 50% pretty and 50% dangerous.
- I don't even know what to say.
- No.
- Yeah.
- Hi, Jesus.
- Jesus, I (beep) told you, Jesus.
- It's a beautiful sunny day
and I'm going for a stroll.
- I just drive more
chill, I think it makes me
a worse driver.
- I don't like how the
hair tickles my face.
(horn honking)
- Sorry.
- Oh my god.
- I can parallel park with
long hair, no problem.
(laughter)
- So my hair is stuck to my headphones.
- [Voiceover] Do you
feel like more (mumbles).
- I feel like a (beep) new man.
- I look like Kid Rock.
- Well I'm walking the
streets of Hollywood with my
gorgeous length hair and
no one's batting an eye,
which is nice because I
feel pretty self-conscious.
- It suits you.
- Yeah.
- You look like Jesus.
- (beep) yeah it does.
I look like Jesus.
- I'm starting to look like a
wild cave woman and this rain
isn't really helping.
- I just feel like a fraud, you know?
Like, I don't know.
Maybe just the wig.
Maybe it's the length of the hair.
- So I'm about to head to
the gym now and today's
been a bit of a pain
because my hair just keeps
getting in the way.
It's almost like something's
always tickling my face.
- I'm taking it off.
- [Voiceover] Why?
- Because it's killing me.
I just took like three
Excedrin Migraine right now.
- It's hot, the hair's in
my face, it (beep) sucks.
- The aesthetic is all
wrong for me I think.
- I enjoyed it a lot more
than I thought I would.
- I felt greasier and dirtier.
- It only looks cool in a few instances.
- I can't just leave, I
have to like put it on,
put the bald cap on, and put the pins in.
I was telling that to one of
my friends and she was like,
"Oh, that's what it's
like to be a woman and
"have long hair."
The struggle is real.
- When I first had the wig,
I felt very self-conscious,
but really people don't care.
- I felt like people were
looking at me differently.
- My girlfriend liked it.
- My girlfriend hated it.
- Because it's so
real-looking, it was kind of
confusing for her, I think.
- She thought it would be
really sexy and I came home and
she was very embarrassed.
- A lot of people were telling
me I was acting differently.
I was walking with more of
a swagger so I could feel
my hair in the wind.
- I think now that I've
seen myself with long hair,
I don't need to see it again.
- It's not me.
- I am totally gonna grow my hair out.
I'm totally into it.
(mid-tempo music)
- 'Sup?